pretty good with the tennis racket oh
yeah are you kidding
are you a good tennis player I'm alright
yeah yeah I'm not gonna lie I'm okay I
worked out with his coach okay for three
months with Larney cool it was in the
movie but yeah I'm on yeah I'm okay I'm
DISA well you look good I can fake it
okay okay Billie Jean King said this
movie's not really about tennis it's
about social reform yeah how would you
describe it the same way or I definitely
yeah because you know you can watch
footage or you can see a documentary
about the actual match but this this
talks about something else and was
interesting was talking to the directors
when we first started and about the fact
that none of us believed this was a
period piece because it's very relevant
there's a lot there's a lot at stake
today that you know was at stake back
then and it's kind of sadly relevant
this is one of those films where you're
playing a character and almost
apologizing while you're playing it no
no because I don't he was it was a joke
to him yeah it was a gag and he was
acting if I was playing I don't think he
was a villain at all because he was just
a self-promoter I don't think he was he
wasn't in either camp he wasn't a
feminist but he wasn't a chauvinist he
was just out to make some money and to
become famous because time had sort of
passed him by he was a champion in the
40s and here he was in the seventies 55
years old playing on the senior circuit
and just bored and wanted to be famous
again and wanted a little piece of the
pie too so that all of that stuff all of
that crazy talk even as a kid I knew
that he was kidding around really so
yeah remember that as a kid oh yeah yeah
I was 11 when the match took place and
it everybody knew there was something
endearing about him and the only way
that could be so was that people knew he
was kidding around because if people
believed he was actually saying the
stuff that he was saying it would have
had a different impact on
is it crazy to think you watched that
match and how many years later you're
actually playing him yeah oh yeah you
know in a million years well when I
found out I was gonna play him I really
went back and started watching
interviews with him and there's a great
interview that he did for 60 minutes
that was so enlightening because if he
talked a little bit about his personal
life and you could see the little cracks
of like the real person there he was
still being the showman but kind of
protesting a little too much about oh
you know my wife doesn't need me and
she's better off without me but it was
all in sort of the same spirit of fun
but you could see the hurt and the pain
underneath it all it was interesting how
how amazing is Emma you guys are both
incredible in this picture she's great
well she's nice picture we're amazing
thank you and the fact that you were
talking I don't know how they did that
but it was it was part of the character
that was really convincing for anyway oh
thanks thanks she's mean she's a great
actor she can you know I remember and I
didn't work too much with her on Crazy
Stupid Love but we had done this scene
together and I remember afterwards
talking to her and saying you're so I
mean it looks like it's effortless for
you like you don't that she doesn't even
never see her trying you never see her
acting and I think that's such a
testament to her that it's it just
always it's just flowing out of her and
you never see her performing so natural
so yeah I think she's she's always great
and obviously I think she did a great
job good good to see you